most of you post really analyzing what's
going to do well in the algorithm and
what your audience wants not what you
actually want to say so many people here
in different parts of their Journey that
have real thoughts about things and have
really powerful observations but most
people keep it inside of them and don't
share it attention is the number one
asset you're putting out consumer
content but you have an opportunity
potentially on other platforms whether
that's LinkedIn or Twitter or other
places for you to show how smart you are
about marketing a lot of you are holding
back your brains for visual execution
and I highly encourage you to consider
putting out some of your
brains